it's been hard to find a home for many
of the stories of war on this channel
who wants a 30-second video on the
Varangian Warriors of Dark Souls 2 but
there are fascinating details here all
the same so here they are in a more
concise format if you learned something
new
consider leaving a like and if you know
everything consider making a youtube
channel about Dark Souls lore let's
start with gravelord nito who has had
relatively little screen time
considering his immense power over death
and the dead for now I want to prove
just how relevant he is as a character
starting with one important item that's
often overlooked
it's the effigy shield found upon a
corpse in the catacombs in an ill-fated
plot to destroy the very gods the
followers of the occult once attempted
to steal the power of gravelord nito the
first of the Dead in Dark Souls the
occult is more accurately defined as
this heretical dark magic used by pagans
who are unaligned with and hostile to
the gods Gwyn and Coe rightly fear the
occult just as the dead fear the divine
it's effective against their following
and kin natos power isn't based on the
occult so if these cultists were
interested in the power of Neto it
follows that nito's power over death
extends to the gods as well and could
easily be used as a weapon against them
after all the dragon eye item states to
be alive is to be vulnerable and the
fiery gods are no exception this tells
us that Neto had power over the gods
leverage and where there's that much
leverage there is a huge story to be
told here but it'll have to wait until
we remaster the prepare to Christ
thank for that one in the end though
it's probably going to be the story of
this immensely powerful entity who just
wants to be left in peace at the end of
the day like the rest of the Dead Leto
was the first of the Dead as in he was
the first to die when the age of
disparity began before it's unclear if
there was even the concept of death
however at the complete other end of the
spectrum was highlord wall Nia who
wished to outlive all others and become
the last of the Dead
to this end he sentenced a great many
souls to death and he conquered the
Lords of many kingdoms and he expanded
the mighty kingdom of the sands known as
Karthus wall near and Karthus deserve
their own video - and they'll be
featured really soon so subscribe for
that there's is this story of victory at
any cost and that ethos that victory at
any cost it characterizes their entire
story and it's a great one right now
though in this video of the curiosity I
want to talk about is why we don't see
their enormous sand Kingdom in game
because it should be right above the
catacombs of Karthus right but it's not
instead above the catacombs of Karthus
we have Ferren and the abyss watchers
and the reason for this is likely the
convergence of the lands if you didn't
know the lands of Dark Souls 3 are
converging together
most likely in response to the Lord's
not sitting on their thrones almost as
if the world is pulling them towards it
this explains the skewed geography of
Dark Souls 3
especially the skewed geography of the
kiln or the Drake II but I want to go a
step further with this theory in regards
to which lands sometimes become
neighbors or next to each other for
example I think the abyss watchers are
specifically above Karthus because they
are the ones that put an end to that
Kingdom I think they are linked to it
according to Hawkwood after all the
abyss watchers will bury a kingdom
first sign of exposure and Karthus was
literally a kingdom that was buried by
the abyss Watchers the legacy of their
kingdom ended up being confined to the
catacombs where that abyss first
appeared and perhaps that battle to
crush Karthus was also the last battle
of the abyss Watchers and as the lands
converged causality sort of linked these
two kingdoms together fate often works
this way in dark souls and I wouldn't be
surprised if this was true speaking of
faith let's talk about the wolf Knights
set originally worn by artorias the
abyss walker' it reads a vanquished
Knight left behind only wolf's blood and
a legacy of duty
the undead legion of Ferren was formed
to bear his torch and the armour of
these abyss watchers suggests their
eventual end that last part isn't
actually an accurate translation in
japanese instead of the armor suggesting
their eventual end the abyss watchers
actually saw their own final moments in
the armor the difference being that they
were actually keenly aware of this abyss
soaked fate that awaited them
this gives way more flavor to these
characters because having an iron will
was a famed characteristic of artorias
and his abyss watchers lived up to that
they persisted in their duty fully aware
that they were literally fighting
against their own inevitable fate that
is an iron will that is worth being
commended for another interesting nuance
of the Japanese translation is the
actual name of the followers of Ferran
these were the hollows or the undead
that trudged after the undead legion
disposing of any stragglers who ended up
falling to the abyss but these followers
of Ferran
more accurately called ghosts revenants
or spirits in Japanese which really
suits them for as we know from before
those in the undead Legion have already
seen their inevitable demise
they're already ghosts their fate to die
is who they are which really suits the
definition of revenant or Spectre or
ghost and if you're a member of the
undead Legion and you have partaken of
the old wolfblood perhaps falling to the
abyss isn't the only grisly fate that
awaits you this is something that passed
me by for the longest time so from what
I hear these creatures are called
lycanthropes in the official guides for
the game lycanthrope means wolf
possessed and seeing as this is the
Ferren swamp it follows that being wolf
possessed would have something to do
with the wolf blood that the abyss
watchers are willingly partaking in it
seems as if there's a potential negative
side effect of this blood something that
turns one into a beast not dissimilar to
what happens in blood-borne in addition
the hollows here are called hunters of
the possessed and they're probably also
responsible for the crucifixion that's
taking place and it turns out those
crosses make pretty good chairs all Beck
was once a Vin homescholar although he
likens it to being more of an assassin
than a scholar he expresses a lot of
resentment for the lack of sorcery he
ended up getting taught what a fool I
was thinking one day I would learn real
sorceries when I became undead I was
exiled from the school but here I am now
exploring the depths of sorcery
the nation of vinhai' and by extension
their white dragon school is pretty
violent place note how they have all
these aggressive and duplicitous
sorceries to their name hell even
big-hat logan a complete social recluse
is famed for his magical arsenal that
emulates weaponry like swords and spears
so you would think that there would have
been some event in this nation's history
that warranted such war based magic
development and it's for this reason
that VIN hime becomes our most likely
victim of a war with the way of white
the miracle magic barrier explains that
there was a short period in history
where clerics and sorcerers opposed one
another it was for this reason that even
the most common way of white cleric
found it necessary to cast some form of
magic barium and so this more simple
common version of the barrier was
derived from novels original great magic
barrier oddly the persecution of
sorcerers in Dark Souls to crops up in
an item description you really wouldn't
expect it to it appears in the Varangian
sword description in Dark Souls 2 if
you've forgotten and no one's gonna
blame you if you have the Varangians
were the Pirates that vendrick forced
into hard labor that no-man's Wharf and
it's only mentioned in a couple of
descriptions but there was actually a
campaign to restrain and capture them
because they were terrorizing at the
northern seas as well as hunting sea
monsters apparently beyond these seas
this description reads is an unexplored
continent said to be the home of things
inhuman I'm always really intrigued by
these parts of the soul series that we
only hear of and we never really see and
in my opinion if there was ever to be a
Dark Souls for one of the few ways they
could go forward is by fulfilling
Aldridge's visions of the age of the
deep sea and this is our only mention of
sea monsters that might be prepared for
the world that might exist in that time
not all people were as easily conquered
as the Varangians were however
throughout all of the stories mirror
remains one of the most resilient
nations even though they said to be
constantly at war within
Mira had a couple of things that were
worth protecting
one was the holy water of Mira which was
this ancient well that is said to have
retained its divinity throughout all
these years
its water scolds the skin of hollows and
undead and I was wondered why hollow
fearing people like vendrick didn't make
a concentrated effort to acquire this
holy water because vendrick definitely
did have his eyes on the wonders of
mirror in addition to their holy water
there was also the wonder known as guy
steel which was this precious alloy that
was created within their country and
mastered by the blacksmith Llewellyn
instead of conquering mirror to obtain
it however vendrick simply bought out
the blacksmith he offered him an obscene
amount of money and so guy Steele was
introduced to drangleic but more than
their steel and their holy water mirror
was known for its Knightly code of honor
such was their legend that even the
peasantry dreamed of becoming Knights
but their chances are said to have been
about one in 10,000 there's another
famous success story told in exactly the
same way except it takes place in fur
OSA and it's about shield list laughs
Ian who was this fearless warrior who
was born a peasant and rose to the rank
of general such was his determination
that he always fought without a shield
on the battlefield so he always went to
battle at risk of his own life and is no
surprise that that inspired his men
however one day he disappeared and one
theory supplies that he tired of how
frail human opponents were and he went
on instead to slay the Dragons of legend
his axe is imbued with lightning and it
appears to support that theory
after this however Carosa was destroyed
by war and its people scattered to a
bunch of other lands as cell swords
makes you wonder what would have
happened if he didn't run off to slay
dragons
the dragons aren't so easily conquered
even dragons that were tamed throughout
the generations in lothric appear to
have turned on their own fortress as
soon as there are no sane knights to
keep them in check amongst the ruins of
this place lothric had one final secret
that we've kind of only really uncovered
now remember how we mentioned the
convergence of lands earlier when we
were talking about the kingdom of
Karthus and how its catacombs drifted
closer with Ferren above them well the
Japanese description for the straight
sword of the law three key Knights
States it is said that the lothric
knights along with their flying dragons
once conquered everything that drifted
the word for drifted is the exact same
one the Japanese used to describe
convergence in other dialogues therefore
it's possible that the lothric Knights
seated upon their wyverns
were this fire-breathing defense force
against that convergence conquering any
kingdoms that would begin to converge
infringe or drift upon the space of
their own so I hope I left you with a
lot to think about and I've never said
this but be sure to ring the bell if you
want to be summoned here immediately
when there's a new video and you know so
you can get the honor the privilege and
the glory of being able to say you were
first earning you the admiration and
envy of your peers
I'll see you fixed
[Music]